all right going to the phones is
Stephanie from Minnesota
hey Stephanie welcome to the show thank
you for taking my call absolutely how
can we help well my husband and I we are
working on baby step number two i'ma
stay at home on so what you guys were
just talking about really kind of
resonates with me where you're doing our
budget we got that all figured out you
know rice and beans but it still just
doesn't feel like enough and I'm trying
to figure out if I should go back to
work if I should just do side hustles
you know what I can do to help
contribute to getting rid of that debt
yeah that's a great question and I feel
like there's a lot of women that are
exactly in your in your spot we hear
this question a lot and so Christy you
actually helped a lot with women and and
getting kind of a side hustle going to
make extra money not only to do it for
their passion and their gifts but also
to bring in some extra income yeah
Stephanie first I just want to say well
done because there's a value on the fact
that you're staying home with your kids
there there's a value on the top care
child care is expensive and your work at
home is not you just sitting around I
know it's our maids and valet
right chefs everything that you do
there's there's a there's a value on
what you do so please don't feel like
I'm not contributing enough because I'm
not working outside the home you are
working inside the home and there's a
value on what you're saving your family
and child care costs so I want to start
with that baseline of you already are
bringing in money for the family by
doing that now if you want to contribute
a little bit more or in a different way
you use your gifts have some you know
side hustle it's easier than ever before
to do that and what I teach people to do
that may just be a good starting point
to explore for you is to start with what
you have your skills your strengths and
your stuff and when you start with what
you have and coming up with an idea for
a side hustle or home-based business it
makes it so easy on you to win quickly
and to turn a profit quickly and to have
income coming in because it's not this
scary thing that you have to go learn a
new skill and buy a bunch of stuff
you're just gonna look around you what
am I good at what do I have experience
in what am I naturally talented at what
stuff I've got a sewing machine maybe I
can so if it's a swimming pool maybe I
can teach you some lessons I've got a
computer maybe I could
hey you know when you look around you
with what you already have you make it
so much easier on you to win and become
successful and bringing money faster and
then it builds your confidence it's more
fun and as a side note you're also
making more money so if you want to
explore that in addition to the value
you're already bringing to the table and
your family for baby step 2 then I would
encourage you to do that and Stephanie I
would love to also send you a copy of my
book business boutique and that is a
plan to start a business so should you
decide to do that at any level even if
you just want to make an extra 500
dollars a year it's gonna help you do
that I love helping people get started
and so if you'll stay on the phone we'll
we'll send you a copy of that but I
think you see this a lot Rachel with
baby step 2 people want to bring in more
money faster because they're so
motivated yeah that's a good thing
that's a really good thing absolutely
for sure but I love that we don't
discount the fact because people get out
of debt all the time and the wife stays
at home and that's what and that's her
job that's what she does so she focuses
on because there's something to be said
that there's a peace of mind right when
the husband comes home from work and
you're there and you're you're helping
out and you're doing you know what you
do at home like that's powerful yes oh
gosh so there's plenty of people in
America Stephanie that are getting out
of debt on one and income so don't lose
hope on that don't think it's impossible
but if there is something that you have
they're like man I really could do this
and and it'd be fun I would enjoy how
the kids are in school and all of that
then that definitely is an option but
don't again discount discount being home
because that is such such a gift that
you're giving your family for sure